[Music]
and take a seat news sit your ass down
monopod submitted by why are you here I
ask myself every day Chris Hanson has
been arrested for bouncing checks to
catch a predator that he was gonna be
caught for for being on my last no I
don't want him to but you know I mean
for comedy I know yeah I mean life for
it it would be ironic
I agree cuz when I saw so I read the
headline it's like Chris Hansen gets own
mug shot but then I stopped reading I
was like is he a predator - but that's
what everyone's probably thinking that's
a league game is he is he poor he's been
running out of money yeah apparently so
he got arrested after bouncing a
thirteen thousand dollar check [ __ ] this
check a lot of money was for several
mugs t-shirts and decal supermarkets
more yeah so he has merge because his
handsome much yeah back in 2015 he
started a Kickstarter I caught my
predator emerged
that's tight merch I like that like
engagement merch like no call me if you
know a 12 year old Chris Hanson a 12
year old wouldn't be if you know a guy
that likes to know he's he's the one
catch I know but he meets the bait
though yeah and they sure should just be
I'm bait bait is the hard part they
predator be it should be like yeah
that's a really good shirt for tight guy
did predator bait
good good baby bootie on call take it
easy take it easy
oh my god that would be genius get Chris
Hanson to interview or Kelly or even
bait our Kelly and our Kelly shows up at
Chris Hansen's like so funny yeah Chris
Hansen doesn't need to do [ __ ] all Chris
Hansen needs to do is do you like
teenage girls he's like what do you mean
g19 he goes I have 19 year old friends I
mean I have 19 year old friends but if
you talk about under illegal I don't do
that
really that is [ __ ] hilarious I love
our Kelly dude no you don't you [ __ ]
ironically sure we want Elliott album on
the way here and the age ain't nothing
but a number and like she's talking
about like love and like how she's like
so infatuated with this dude I'm like oh
you're just thinking about art Kelling
you're 15 but that was an anthem back in
the days you know it's like I a lot of
people they do pen the the the song on
the rider but they're also writing what
is in the streets like they're just you
know Tupac uses telling stories of the
hood so it's like when they were telling
that like I knew so many chicks 13
dating 18 year olds I need so many
chicks 15 dating 23 year olds it was
like so normal for sure I did know like
my best friend she got her first kiss
from this dude that was like 24 she was
like 13 or something so I know that
that's very real
yeah but where I'm sitting as a
grown-ass woman looking back at that
this is 13 when I was 14 I was trying to
get molested by a 22 year old girl we
don't we don't I was like that unless
you're a teacher like there's a lot of
teachers no even I wanted my junior high
teacher to take me places there was a
there was a girl it was a girl in high
school that had a huge crush on our
world history teacher but he was a
little younger yeah but he was very
handsome dude but it was [ __ ] weird
because she always was next to him as a
TA but she just it looked a little
[ __ ] odd and it turns out that she
was like madly in love with him
throughout all of high school actually
got a little ostracized for that though
so I don't I don't know if like you know
I like going down in age was weird like
let's say you're 20 right you don't want
a [ __ ] 13-year old you want like a 20
year old or a 25 year old or whatever
right like you don't I don't know that's
a guy I didn't and then the older you
get let's say like mid-20s then you'll
go okay maybe 18th school but there was
there was a lady though Miss Oda and did
you guys have one of those [ __ ]
teachers those like TAS they were bad as
[ __ ] miss Oda
finest [ __ ] dude mr. Oda just sounds old
I could cafeteria lady Miss Oda me agent
don't raisin so she must have been -
well she was the TA so she was super
young so she so she was whatever we were
really I will say this though I think
she was banging some of the football
dudes because she always had all the
football guys around her 24/7 and she
had nothing to sports dude you're just
like a commenter I think she was banging
them because like they were just walking
next to her like you could tell not
walking that Stora hanging out with her
after school they all had their nose
pressed up against her ass when she
basically yeah but it's you like a dog
I've never been wrong never ever in my
life don't you [ __ ] dare Chris Hansen
why you gotta money what happened
got it on my name no he did this
Kickstarter back in 2015 where he was
trying to create this new show backed by
supporters called Hansen versus Predator
and so he promised a lot of these
backers like depending on what you
pledged that you'll get certain types of
merch so that's why he ordered like a
whole bunch of merch
it totaled - twelve thousand nine
hundred ninety eight dollars in five
senses thirteen thousand dollars and he
sent them a check but then the check
bounced and then he sent them another
check for a little bit more and then
that check bounced as well and so
finally that's when the merch company
the company had created the merchants
we're like you know what we had to call
the cops cuz we need to get paid for all
this because he took the merch - that's
but his checks kept bouncing how do
Texas home on the ground how do you how
do you write a check without like
checking your it's so easy it's [ __ ]
digital now yeah don't look at their
bank account like they have like
accountants especially if like imagine
being as rich as Chris Hanson right like
well she's not very rich well when he
was having his show yeah I'm pretty sure
he was getting good [ __ ] money right
so you build a habit of never looking
cuz you just have unlimited money and
then you do this for like a decade and
then you just have bad spending habits
and then you don't even make as much as
you used to and you just keep swiping
and swiping
and you oh I forget that he wanted to
catch a predator from 24 2004 to 2007
dude it only lasted three years yeah
well the best shows on earth maybe
because it keeps circulating online also
because South Park that's true
remember South Park but they made fun of
them is funny well apparently that was
this dude that came out on the show he
ended up committing suicide oh so I
don't know if that was the reason
operator did yeah well I'm like is that
a big no I'm saying maybe that led to
the show to be canceled oh he commits
suicide on the show no not unless he was
on it remember that show cheaters and
then the host got stabbed one times oh
my god yeah and then they had a switch
host and the idol no big deal right that
dude did gets bad that's just really sad
because like the guy flipped out in the
middle of like he catches people
cheating on their spouses and so they
start getting heated and this middle man
dude was like so [ __ ] pissed that
this the hoes like caught the UH put him
on blast yeah and then yeah you got well
I mean it was bound to happen especially
the way he caught them and how smug he
was about yeah how do you do you do you
think this was a good thing to do like I
would stab the [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah whoo I
[ __ ] hate and I [ __ ] hate this guy
do you guys watch people's court that
dude it yes yeah Judge Joe Brown
you know it's Mathis no it's the ladies
Latinos Judy uh-huh no oh anyway oh she
has the long hair the long hair one
okay right but you know like once they
settle you know who's guilty who's not
and then they talk to the white guy
who's like all right he like kind of
gives you a recap he's on the streets on
the hallway no he's the hallway guy okay
yeah yeah the holly and you'll be like
well you didn't seem very prepared this
time maybe next time you should be more
prepared how do you feel about that yeah
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] I
just watched you [ __ ] dick yeah he
does I think he does that to like rile
you up so that you can get give him
better cause Judge Joe Brown is the
[ __ ] [ __ ] I love him he sits like this
when he's judging people on the side
like this so would you tell the meat
boys that you ain't got no respect for
your mom all y'all daddy
are you chilling on a portrait what's
going on is like chilling let me tell
you something up you guys so much
goddamn tongue you got that for ten rows
of teeth [ __ ] but that's a crazy
[ __ ] dude
I love him dad to ever tell the story of
how it was a Joe's hole for a while what
the Joe's okay so back when I was like
super [ __ ] broke I was just like any
job like I was on unemployment I was
looking for jobs I like I was just
taking like any job that I could yeah
and I got called to be I was signed up
on every casting site you know and I got
called up one day to be as like
background for Judge Joe Brown
which I didn't even know that those were
hired extras I was just like okay but it
wasn't just like the extras it was like
they hire three specific girls to sit in
the front row and be like really like
done up and like really paying attention
the whole time like really into it and
they paid us $250 for the day and we
were treated like cast like we would
have lunch with Joe Joe Brown judge Wow
we got the catered stuff and then all
the extras over here were cast by a
different company and they got like 40
bucks for the day so I had no idea that
it was like that until I got there and
we had to like have five different
outfits because we were changing it as
if we was different days or whatever but
yeah if you look I judged around there's
three specific girls that will always be
in the front like all like like this and
they call him Joe's hos
yeah and I didn't know that and then I
did it for maybe like three they kept
calling me back and I did it for like
three weeks and then I I started hearing
that like I did know you were a Jose Ho
Nikki I saw you up to show Brown for my
people that saw me on YouTube you know
and I was like a Jose oh that's [ __ ]
tight dude dude you're so lucky and you
get to eat what Joe eats
yeah and you get to listen to some like
dumbass people fighting like some of
them are like yes
no one could laugh yeah like you're
allowed to like smile with a little bit
like have a reaction but but yeah you're
I just love that guy cuz I don't know
how you could judge people at the same
time and look like you don't give a [ __ ]
he's like the best at it dude I [ __ ]
love that show man yo you remember that
old referee for Jerry Springer the guy
that broke everyone up he was the life
dude he was like a he was like a boxing
rep and he became a judge he was like a
bald white guy no dawg he was the bet he
was so [ __ ] mean I loved it what the
[ __ ] is name you to do your job I can't
watch too many of those shows because
after like five to ten minutes I start
feeling stupider and stupider and
stupider it actually pisses me off
I've done like the argument oh yeah it's
would imagine if you just got to live in
that world I did that's why I had
classmates like that all day long I
could be a judge easy
and I was like with those type of cases
it's pretty like clear-cut you know it I
mean because if that's what they're
dealing with on the regular I could
easily because the cases are always like
you let your cousin borrow your car
they're always somehow related right and
in the positive and then your cousin
gets it scratched yeah the mall and then
now you're claiming that your cousin
stole it from you because even their
defenses are so stupid it is pretty dumb
it would be like some [ __ ] like that
right where they like scratch the car
and they're like well he scratched the
car five o'clock yawn it was at 7
o'clock
why did you say that you just admitted
to the courts like one roommate is
irresponsible and never pays rent and
they're trying to make a ton of excuses
not to pay mm-hmm I would be like dude
you just need a reset life and be a
child again going around something wrong
with reverse fishing they wearing
glasses before reversing man he needs to
catch predators again make some money
again the reason why he created this
Kickstarter and then it actually raised
let me see I think it was 90,000 oh my
god what did he do with the monies and
then I don't know but a whole bunch of
commenters are people donors they left
comments on the Kickstarter page cuz
they Manthey never received anything
even said he had to sell a boat to come
the money to pay the merch people but
he's over later believe them he actually
turned to me up into he was just like
yeah that's funny he had to sell a boat
he was probably so much in debt he had
to use that money for other [ __ ] you
like Nick Cage how he had like five
castles or whatever had a sell his
castle that just sounds like
overspending to me sold my Maserati you
know but he would he would collect like
doubles or triples of everything like it
wasn't just like I have a Ferrari it's
like I have three Ferraris I have three
castles I don't know but I already know
what the logic is about that so one is
for you to drive right and the other one
is for you to have just in case you [ __ ]
up the one that you drive so you have an
extra for the extra because I do that
[ __ ] wants to show people because it's
always clean yep
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]